صباح الخير لورين كريستين ،
مصادر متعددة أخبرتني أن تقرير
مدير المخابرات الوطنية
متوقع في وقت مبكر من يوم الخميس كنا
ننتظر هذا التقرير لفترة طويلة
وقد تم
تمريره فعليًا إلى قانون في عام 2019 لكن إدارة ترامب
اختارت بعد ذلك  تجاهله ، إنه تقرير غير سري
صادر عن مكتب مدير
المخابرات الوطنية وهو مطلوب
لتوضيح
ما وجده مجتمع المخابرات
حول ما يعرفه المسؤولون
السعوديون وما فعلوه الآن في عام 2018 بعد مقتل خاشقجي ،
قيمت المخابرات المركزية بثقة عالية
أن  أمر ولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان بنفسه
بالقتل الوحشي لخاشقجي ،
الأمير بالطبع
ينفي ذلك لأننا نعلم بوجود
رابط آخر بين محمد بن سلمان
كما هو معروف وقتل
خاشقجي في اسطنبول ، حصلنا على
وثائق من قضية محكمة كندية
كشفت عنها.  أن الطائرتين النفاثتين الخاصتين
اللتين حملتا فريق الضرب السعودي
كانتا تديرهما شركة
ولي العهد  قبل
أقل من عام من الجريمة المروعة
التي أمر بها بتحويل شركة الطيران هذه
إلى صندوق الاستثمار في البلاد
الذي
يتحكم فيه.  قال إنه
يُظهر خطًا
مباشرًا لقتل جمال خاشقجي ، لقد طلبنا من المسؤولين السعوديين
ردًا
ولم نحصل على أحد ، بينما قال
الرئيس جو بايدن إنه
قرأ التقرير الذي رفعت عنه السرية ، ولم يقدم
أي تفاصيل
قالها للتو إنه سيفعل  التحدث
مع الملك السعودي سلمان
قريبًا وهو ما لم يفعله بعد ،
وهو أمر ملحوظ لأنه كان في
منصبه
لأكثر من شهر ، لورا كريستين ،
حسنًا ، دعنا نحضر
المحرر الدبلوماسي الدبلوماسي الدولي نيك
روبرتسون
الذي قدمته على نطاق واسع في
العلاقة بين الولايات المتحدة والسعودية.
كيف يمكن لهذا التقرير غير
المصنف أن يغير الحسابات السياسية لإدارة بايدن
إعادة
أكثر إدانة الأدلة التي تأتي
إلى المجال العام
التي تربط محمد بن سلمان بشكل
أعمق ربما أو تضع الجسد على
عظام تحليل وكالة المخابرات المركزية في جميع
الاحتمالات أنه أمر بالقتل أو
هذا هو نوع الافتراض العملي
هناك المزيد من الأدلة.  لدعم ذلك
، كلما كان من الصعب على الرئيس
بايدن أن تكون
له علاقة أه بالمملكة
أه علاقة لا أه
مبيعات الأسلحة إلى المملكة العربية السعودية على سبيل المثال
بكل بساطة أن الملك يتقدم في السن على
الأرجح خلال قيادة الرئيس بايدن
سيصبح ولي العهد
ملكًا وهذا هو التوقع الذي
تثيره مخاوف المملكة العربية
السعودية واعتقادهم أن التقرير
لن يحتوي على سلاح دخان لن يربط
مباشرة
أه ولي العهد بقتل
خاشقجي لكنهم
يشتبهون ويخافون.  أنه يمكن أن تكون هناك
تسريبات من أولئك الذين يريدون
أن تفرض الولايات المتحدة نوعًا من العقوبات
التي من شأنها تقليص مبيعات الأسلحة ،
فما هي سياسة  التكلفة الإجمالية لذلك بالنسبة
للرئيس بايدن مع الولايات المتحدة
، المملكة العربية السعودية هي أقوى
حليف للولايات المتحدة وأهمها الآن
في الخليج ، فهي لاعب ضخم
في المنطقة ومن المرجح أن
تصبح أكثر
تبتعدًا عن دعم أه  المملكة
العربية السعودية
عندما ذهب الرئيس بايدن عن
طريقه ليقول إنه سيدعم المملكة العربية السعودية
في الدفاع عن المملكة العربية السعودية من الهجمات ،
لكن الابتعاد عن المملكة العربية السعودية
يلقي حقًا بإمكانية فتح الباب أمام
السعوديين وهذا ما أسمعه من
مصادر
سعودية  سوف يتطلعون إلى أنهم يستطيعون التطلع أكثر إلى
الصين
وروسيا للحصول على الدعم العسكري وأنواع أخرى من
الدعم وفي بيئة عالمية حيث
أصبحت الصين
لاعباً مهيمناً بشكل متزايد
يتحدى
القاعدة الأمريكية إذا كنت ستنشر في جميع أنحاء العالم
حول
العالم  هذه بيئة صعبة للغاية
بالنسبة للرئيس بايدن
للتنقل فيها ،
نعم إدانة المملكة العربية السعودية لها
عواقب عدم إدانة المملكة العربية السعودية
موقف صعب ليكون في نيك
روبرتسون شكرا جزيلا لك على ذلك